all right new game started um
pretty good opponent an international
international master from from germany
here
golden eagle this is um
i think martin martin creamer some
yes he's got um solid grand master
strength
he's above 2500
and she's just lacking one norm or
something very close to being a grand
master
okay i played the nimzo and um this is a
fairly
topical variation which i'm well i know
it's a topical variation but i don't
know
the details um i know you could play
this and um
trying to get some play in the center
um white has made all these
somewhat strange looking queen moves
he's got bishop h6
also has an idea but i've got 98
okay i don't know the exact um
theory here
need to need to improvise
okay well d4 maybe you can put some
pressure on d4
with rook t1 so maybe
i should try to prepare e5
with some with something like this here
yeah i was um
i just i just saw this move right after
i played them
queen e7 yeah this
um isn't good news
but maybe i can take and um 94 this is
so terrible
yeah it's not great okay i don't think i
have much choice
if he goes some bishop
f4 i can go i think rook t8
and but he's got rook t1 maybe f6 then
join f6 e5
of course you actually shouldn't play
such a
sharp line without any detailed
knowledge
but okay i want to vary in the openings
here
for the videos and not play the stuff i
usually play all the time so
you get some some variety of openings
and once in a while
accidents are bound to happen
okay take now
yeah maybe he just manages to um to keep
keep his
pawn on d6
what else can i play knight c5 after b4
looks looks stupid and now he's got um
the opportunity to most likely play b
form
let's say i play rook g8 he has got c5
b6 before him
he will cover this
maybe try b6 myself
i'm not quite sure maybe it isn't
completely completely clear
i'm still um
yeah i'm not i'm not really super
great in development but he's got issues
as well
so
threatening rook c8 of course he can
play f4 but
if he plays f4 i might drop to d7 with
the idea of knight c5
okay he's opening up it is he's opening
up the position further which makes
sense of course
in a way to get rid of the weakness
but i'm not so
quite quite
quick in development here so maybe there
are still
some some ideas so
yeah yeah of course but
still g2 is somewhat weak
okay we have to take d6
i might go a4 i am okay but but then i
could maybe take them
because a5 is also hanging well
yeah it should be it should be white
white should be better of course
this i didn't expect at all which
i'm not sure
yeah maybe it's just just a good move
i don't have any entry squares
i could i could go knight c4 yeah and
if he takes
it takes on a5 i got rook f1
come on
rook f1 of course rook c2
i meant that if he takes rook takes a
bishop a5 i can i can go
c2 and the variation i was
getting at was rook f2 rook c4 and rook
f1
i'm not quite sure what what he plays
now
a3 is also hanging and d2 is hanging and
isn't this so clear-cut
okay on rook c2 what what then
of course you can just ignore it yeah he
does ignore it
yeah he's got this um this idea of um
time warning of the rook check of course
but they can of course enter with the
bishop not sure e4 or f3
maybe you can go rook d2 now
all right
yeah okay
of course i can i can still try to fight
a bit but
not sure why i didn't took them
actually i wanted to resign
he's still this is the wrong wrong
colored bishop so
there's a little amount of hope
rook f3 i'm just an idiot
what is
he really did everything to to to get me
into
somehow into a fighting position here
of course not
yeah it's still lost yeah but
this was entirely unnecessary to to
to get give me even the slightest chance
here and um
after rookie three i just need to
exchange rooks and
okay this is maybe possible somehow and
get into
into a8 to make a draw
you can just you can just take h3 and
it's just over
no no idea why it doesn't take it's
completely completely
unnecessary and yeah okay
but i was i was in trouble right of the
opening
queen g6 was um yeah i don't know
i don't know how this is played at all
so maybe um
here's something else i don't know a5 97
i don't know
i don't know i will display it
yeah okay next game